breaking news overnight president
trump's actions leading up to the
january 6 riot are now under criminal
investigation by the department of
justice now this comes after weeks of
hearings on capitol hill with evidence
and testimony from many of his former
allies about the effort to undermine the
2020 election results yesterday the
former president delivered his first
speech in washington was his first since
leaving office where he appeared to lay
the groundwork that he's going to run
again for president jeff begaye has more
from the department of justice jeff good
morning to you
dale it is too early to tell whether the
former president is a target of this
criminal investigation here at doj but
one thing is for certain people in his
orbit are definitely in the crosshairs
of prosecutors investigators right now
we're told focused on seized phone
records and that fake elector scheme
that if successful
would have potentially overturned the
results or at least tried to overturn
the results of the 2020 election
and i won a second time did much better
the second time
did a lot better former president donald
trump repeated his false claims of
election fraud on tuesday
as the justice department deepened its
investigation into the election
aftermath
if i renounced my beliefs and just took
it easy
the persecution of donald trump would
stop immediately cbs news has confirmed
the doj prosecutors
working on the january 6 investigation
question witnesses before a grand jury
including two top advisers to then vice
president mike pence i did receive a
subpoena for the federal grand jury and
i comply with that subpoena part of the
investigation is focusing on potential
fraud after the 2020 election and the
alleged efforts by trump allies to use
fake electors supporting mr trump
the other focus is on the alleged
conspiracy to stop a government
proceeding and the certification of
electoral votes
as prosecutors look into the pressure
campaign on then vice president mike
pence
he was also back in d.c on tuesday for a
dueling speech
offering a vision for a gop that can
embrace trump loyalists i don't know
that the president and i differ on
issues
but we may differ on focus
this doj investigation is different from
the current congressional inquiry which
cannot result in a criminal prosecution
but committing members have supported a
criminal probe into former president
trump i sure as hell hope they have a
criminal investigation at this point
into donald trump in an interview with
nbc news on tuesday attorney general
merrick garland said that no one is
above the law we intend to hold everyone
anyone who was criminally responsible
for events surrounding january 6
for any attempt to interfere with the
lawful transfer of power from one
administration to another accountable
almost daily now the ag is peppered with
questions about whether he could indict
or charge a former president
it is a weighty decision and it would be
unprecedented in the past the former
president has denied any wrongdoing
gail
all right jeff thank you very much